hi there this is an lstm cell
or the computation graph of an lstm cell
it is pretty hideous as you can see but
what i'm about to show you is even
more hideous this is the computation
graph of the
lstm cell augmented with
error units evincing the connectivity
scheme of the predictive
coding algorithm so you may see that
there are
appearing these little red arrows right
here
that are so-called error units and these
are necessary for an algorithm called
predictive coding
which is an algorithm that is a
biologically
plausible alternative to backprop
and that's what we're going to look at
today specifically this paper
as you can see it is quite a thorough
paper
um it is called predictive coding
approximates back prop along arbitrary
computation
graphs and have you ever heard a more
descriptive title of what's in a paper
so the authors are
baron millage alexander chance and
christopher l buckley
this paper as the title says
it looks at this predictive coding
algorithm
and it shows that this approximates back
prop
and we'll see that this approximates um
is in terms of there is an inner
iteration in the predictive coding
algorithm and the more you run that and
under certain assumptions this
approximates the back propagation
algorithm
and the new thing in this paper is a
long
arbitrary computation graphs so
there have been papers before describing
predictive coding this algorithm
in various sub settings like fully
connected layers and so on
uh the fact that it approximates back
prop there
however this paper shows that that's
actually the case for
arbitrary computation graphs under
certain assumptions
predictive coding approximates the back
propagation algorithm
why is this important because
the back propagation algorithm isn't
exactly
biologically plausible so
they say right here in the abstract back
propagation of error
or short backdrop is a powerful
algorithm for training machine learning
architectures through
end-to-end differentiation recently has
been shown that backprop in multi-layer
perceptrons can be approximated using
predictive coding a biologically
plausible process
theory of cortical computation which
relies
solely on local and hebian updates so
the difference between
back propagation and predictive coding
is
exactly this point that predictive
coding relies
solely on local and hebbian updates
okay and the keyword i think is local
so in in a neural network you have some
sort of
input x and you ship it through
many layers layer layer layer
layer and then you have an output y-hat
and then you compare that output
using a some kind of loss function
with your with your true output that you
want
and then there is this backwards phase
right here and in this backwards phase
you want to derive gradients for
each of the layers weights so each of
these layers has a weight
associated with it i'm not going into
greek letters again
um so this is w i don't know w
3 w 2 is here and so on
so what you want to get out is you want
to say
how do i need to change w in order to
change
my loss for the better so what you want
is this gradient this gradient right
here and back propagation does a very
natural decomposition
namely uh if you have these hidden
states in here so
x is transformed to hidden state h0 h1
h2 h3 so that is the latent
representation
if you want for example weight
if you want to know how to change weight
or let's say weight two
um the back propagation algorithm
decomposes this
into the derivative according
to the hidden state at layer 2
multiplied by the derivative of the
hidden state
by the weight so this is what you would
sort of learn in a beginner's course of
deep learning
this decomposition and of course in this
part right here
this part decomposes into
del l for h3 and then
h3 by h2
so this is the standard back propagation
algorithm you can clearly see in the
in the formula the computation graph it
goes from the l it flows backward
to h3 right so to h3
and then from h3 it flows to h2
and then from h2 it flows to
w2 so that's sort of the flow of the
gradient backwards through the network
and that's pretty cool because it allows
us to
run gradient descent on arbitrary
computation graphs which ultimately
enable deep learning
including frameworks like tensorflow
pytorch or the older ones like
theano or lua torch even autograd things
like this
it's pretty cool but it's not really
plausible in the brain because
neurons are not bi-directional like this
neurons generally i'm i'm so i'm not a
neuroscientist or anything but these
neurons they have some sort of soma
and then you have this this axon right
and then this axon goes into
many different of these synapses to its
to its children and it kind of docks
onto the somas
of or of on the dendrites of
the other uh neurons and this is not
bi-directional this is generally
here there's unidirectional signal in
this direction
and there are so called feedback
connections so from these neurons to
the dendrites of this neuron but you
cannot really
send this gradient information you
cannot
send this sort of vector gradient
information
and you cannot do so in this sort of
sweep
so in the brain it's probably not the
case that the layer propagates
forward and then sort of waits for a
synchronized backward pass uh across the
network
in order to update itself all of this
needs to happen much more in parallel
much more local so that things are only
considering
local information of global information
right here for example you need the
global
gradient in the update of w2
and you need to have that back
propagated that's not plausible so
predictive coding comes along
and today we'll look mainly actually at
how predictive coding works of course
this paper is about extending it to
arbitrary computation graphs which is
cool because they do predictive coding
for
cnns rnns and even lstms
and if you look at their so let's first
jump into the numerical results
if you look at their numerical results
they have lots of these plots
where they basically show uh we did this
network we train it with backprop and
then we train it with predictive coding
and the lines are just the same and so
it's pretty convincing evidence
even if you go super duper deep um
and they do i think rnns with up to 100
layers or 100 time steps unrolled
so the empirical evidence that
predictive coding
approximates back prop is certainly here
and we'll look at what predictive coding
is how it works
and how it works along arbitrary
computation graphs
so that's today's paper and i
hope you enjoy it if you do don't
hesitate to
share it out and subscribe
all right so
all right so this graphic right here
compares the two
algorithms in principle on top very much
what i've
said so far uh the back propagation
algorithm
somehow has this signal it propagates
forward
okay and then at some point there's an
output and if you want to train it
there is a label you compare that to the
output that will give you an error and
by derivation a gradient
and that gradient is now back propagated
according to the chain rule
according to the back propagation
algorithm you can see
it's very much what i've drawn the
predictive coding algorithm is a little
bit
different and it's
honestly not super clear from
this graphic right here i find this
graphic to be to be a bit
confusing um but you can see
first of all there is this introduction
of these
of these error nodes in the computation
graph
right here and there also seems to be
the introduction of these
new hat whatever that is um
so so we're sort of first going to dive
into
the math and then we're going to check
out
how the algorithm works as such so
the math right here is a little bit
it's a little you have to think a little
bit differently than you do
in backprop so first of all they say
we define a generative model which
parameterizes the value of
each vertex given the feed forward
prediction of its parents
according to this distribution and a
factorized variational posterior
where p denotes the set of parents and c
denotes the set of children of a given
node x
so this is this is very um special
namely this turns the entire
algorithm into a sort of a guessing game
into
a into a variational
approximation algorithm so what they're
basically saying
is that signal in this type of algorithm
signal isn't
just forward propagated but signal
is signal is forward guess it's like a
bit of a guess so you have a
signal right here v i
and uh this is a node in your neural
network
and when you forward propagate the
signal maybe this is
a fully connected layer right here so
it's simply
multiplying it by parameter you're not
you're not going to obtain the next
layer's
signal what you're going to obtain is a
guess for the next layers signal right
here
you're only guessing you're assuming
that um you're sort of
assuming that the true
next signal is somewhere in the vicinity
of this so what you do is actually
assume this is a
gaussian with the mean that you predict
it but then
there is a fair a good chance it's
somewhere around
here so what you do is you always you'll
guess
the next layer's signal by forward
propagating
your own signal and you're
you're so you're not directly computing
it okay
and the model that we have for that here
you know it's
why do we do this we do this um because
we're also not so sure about this one
right here
okay so this entire thing is built upon
we're pretty sure what the input is and
we're pretty sure
what the label is of a data point but
um without you know we're not
we assume we're not really sure what the
intermediate
layers are and we're going to run sort
of an update procedure
on these um on our guesses of
where these intermediate signals are and
that's going to be this predictive
coding algorithm so it's called
predictive
coding i guess because you always only
predict
where the next layer signal might be
and you refine that prediction in the
series of
inner iteration steps and that all
before
you even do a parameter update so
there's going to be an inner iteration
to determine
what the forward values are of the
network
and this is very different from um
backprop there is just a single forward
pass right then you know the values and
then there is a backward pass
here there is as as you'll see there is
a single forward pass but then there is
an inner
loop to refine the forward pass
um before there is a backward pass and
we need this because
we only do this sort of local updates
you'll you'll see in a second so
the the gaussian i i just drew
um so the assumption the assumption is
going to be that we refine
iteratively refine these up these
guesses of where v
i is and of course um here you'll see
that if i
if i change vi to be down here
my next guess so this is at time step t
my guess is this my time step t plus one
is this of course if i apply the same
fully connected layer
my new guess is going to be down here
somewhere
and so the
assumption here that we're going to make
is
that they you can see
the value of each vertex is
a is this model
right here this is the generative model
so it's a probability distribution
depending on the parents and we're going
to approximate that
by this variational posterior which as
you can see
doesn't depend on the parents anymore
so um it basically says that the
distribution
stays the stays is not it's not
conditional it sort of
stays the same um not sure if i express
this quite correctly
but you can see right here they assume a
gaussian for the generative model
that's dependent on
on these uh things and then the the
posterior
is simply a factorized gaussian and the
variational approximation algorithm
simply makes the kl divergence between
this variational
posterior and the true assumed posterior
small and they can prove that this is
equal
to these errors and the errors are going
to be
the errors between
what's predicted and what's guessed um
yeah it's best if we if we
so if i extend this right here
right i have v zero okay v zero i'm
pretty sure what it is because it's my
input
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to forward
guess what v1 is so this is my guess of
v1
now from v1 i
am going to guess what v2 is and at the
beginning
you know my guess of v1 is the same
as my forward prediction i have no other
reason i have no reason to assume it's
anywhere else so i'm just going to draw
this on top
of v1 right here so since you know it
could be anywhere
it could be anywhere in the vicinity
here
but i'm going to assume it's the same i
have no reason to do so otherwise
and then i'm going to predict
v2 okay and v2 let's say that's already
my output layer and this is my guess of
v2
that's already my output layer but but
now um
[Music]
we're going to compare v2 to our true
output what we desire our label
l and there's going to be an error okay
so there's going to be
an error right here and
what the predictive coding algorithm
does is it basically says
well look v2 could be actually anywhere
here anywhere around this thing it's
most likely in the middle but it could
be anywhere
and it's actually quite possible that
it's closer
to this label than we initially
guessed so it takes this error right
here this red error
and it says i'm going to update my guess
of v2
a little bit closer into that direction
so
i don't have here is a new color so v2
is going to be a little bit closer here
it's it's possible right is we
we simply guessed v2 so it could also be
there it's a little bit less likely
um it's a little bit less likely
because it's not in the middle of the
gaussian but v2 could be where
l is right but now
um i have to sort of communicate this
error back
to the last one and the trick here is
that we don't communicate the global
gradient but we only communicate these
local error signals so this first red
arrow here is our
first error signal and we are going to
communicate that
thing back to the to the previous layer
so the difference between v2 and v
and here is a a fully connect let's say
this is a fully connected layer
what we're going to send back to the
last layer is this information of
see you predicted v2 hat but actually
you should predict v2 um
please update yourself such that that
doesn't
you know that's that's a bit closer so
now we're going to update our guess of
v1
and say well if we moved v1 a little bit
over
here that would predict
v2 to be up here right with the same
fully connected layer
and if we if if that's the case then
v2 would be a little closer
to the true label so we're going to move
v1
over here now we're not going to move it
fully because um
so this is a sort of optimization there
is a there is a
force keeping it to where our original
guess is
but there is also a force drawing it in
the direction
of this of this error signal you can see
um so we're going to say well if we just
move v1
to up here we would predict the perfect
v2
but also it's less likely so we're going
to find like some sort of a trade-off
where it's still quite likely under our
gaussian assumption
um but it will predict a little bit more
of the correct label
and so on so this if we had a longer
computation graph this would
then sort of every node in the
computation graph would ask itself
i i'm going to guess my own value
at a place that is pretty close
to my original guess coming from the
forward propagation
but also is consistent with
the output of the next layer
and the output of the next layer of
course here is this this v2
right so the logic isn't i need to make
the loss small the logic is
well if the next signal is v2 then i
can't be in the middle here
i must be a little bit more up here
because you know i
i my signal runs through the fully
connected layer and outputs
v2 so i am probably more up here
so you can see that if you have a
computation graph v0
v1 hat uh v2 hat
v3 hat and so on um
if at the end you have a lost signal
you're sort of
distributing distributing that loss
um across this entire chain so you're
kind of building
this guest chain of values
v3 and so on and
um sorry that's
that's the output node which is close to
the loss
you're moving all of these things and
now
once you've done this once you've done
this you can
do one step of parameter updates so once
you've guessed
all the nodes well you can go ahead and
say
okay this is this is a configuration
that is at equilibrium
in this sort of algorithm and now
here are here is fully connected layer
one so
here is um here is
w zero here is w1
w2 and so on w3 so now we can go ahead
and actually update these weights
such that the initial guesses that we
had
and where we truly think the signal is
are closer together okay so we're now
going to
update the weights in order to minimize
all of these
individual errors and this is also can
be done locally
so you see that the parameter update
step here is now a local one because
we've computed all of these errors
um between where we initially guess the
signal is and where we
sort of think it should be now we can
minimize these errors so
what i've drawn here is actually not
it's not exactly the algorithm but i
hope you get the point so
step one is you sort of guess
where all the stuff is initially
then at the end you get an error signal
right this is an error signal then you
distribute that
error signal backwards and that is
now that is not the same as distributing
a gradient i know it looks the same
but it is not the same and so i have to
say
that you know they say oh this is only
local and so on this doesn't require a
backward sweep i think
when i look at this algorithm it very
much does require a backwards sweep
so very much it goes from the back to
the front in fact it goes from the back
to the front
many times now you can do that in
parallel so this node here
can update so to finish the argument
here as i said before
then you kind of wiggle on these notes
to find out oh this
should probably be more here this one
should probably be more here
this one should probably be more here in
order to
um in order to satisfy
in order to make that error smaller
and the point is that the parameter
update step now is a local one okay so
the parameter update step now
only needs these local errors between
where you initially guessed and where
your
refined iterative guess is after
distributing the error
through the network and this can all
happen in
parallel okay this this um all of this
updating sending information around and
so on this can be parallelized but
it does require a backward sweep if you
ask me
okay so there are two
equations so the the there's two things
right here
there is first as we said there is a
phase
where the guesses of where our
vertex units are where our hidden
representations are
are refined and this is given by these
dynamics right here so you see that
vi changes with time
according to this
thing right here f is the variational
free energy
so this this algorithm sort of falls out
from the math
of assuming these um assuming these
generative models right here under
the assumption that they are these
gaussians okay
um so under under this assumption
if you calculate the kl divergence um
it turns out to come out to this
algorithm
right here so how does the how do we
need to update the node
vi the node vi
is updated according to this gradient
and this gradient is
as we said only computed as properties
of local
things so the first thing is e i
which is that's so again if we have
this is our initial guess of vi
and then here is our refined guess of vi
e i is the error right here
that's that's sort of we need to stay
close to our initial guess
but also we want to go into the
direction
such that um into this direction right
here
so e j j is the children of v
i j are the children and this thing
right here
says how do i need to change my guess of
v i
to make um to make it
fall more in line with vj and you see
here that's vj
uh the initial thing but then
of course the error is so the error j
is going to be the difference between v
j
and v j hat so ultimately
you are guessing you're saying how do i
need to change v
i in order to make it more commensurate
with v
j after going through the
the layer okay so this um this
derivative right here
this is going to involve the derivative
of whatever the fully connected layer or
the conv layer
and so on so there is not
there's not no derivatives in this
algorithm but there are only
sort of these local derivatives so
e i is going to be the difference here
and then
we'll have the fully connected layer
using w
gives you v j hat but also your
refined guess gives you v
j and the error j
is going to be this thing right here
okay
so as you want to stay close right here
but also you want to um make
v i such that it outputs v j
um such that it also minimizes that
error
okay sort of
um yeah it's it's hard to it's hard to
draw these things but i hope i've
explained it in multiple ways right now
that it's at least a little bit clear
how this works
and at the end once you've reached
equilibrium
of all of your guesses of um
all of your guesses of where the next
nodes are
what you do is you update your
parameters here
in a local fashion you can see right
here what you need is this error
of the if layer and
you multiply that by this derivative and
this derivative
is simply the local derivative of your
hidden representation with respect to
your
layer okay so this is very akin to in
the back propagation algorithm
h i do w
i this is just this local derivative so
using the update the update step of the
weights now only requires
local derivatives and that's the point
so here it's in this pseudo code
things are a little bit a little bit
unclear in this
but we'll do so for the entire data set
x is the data point and l is the label
you fix the start so you fix v0
then you go you do the forward pass so
you do this once
you these are your initial guesses um
these hat
things you can see the hat things are
always computed from the parents
you compute the output error right here
and then begin backwards iteration phase
of the descent on the free energy so
here you see
there is this inner loop while not
converged and
this is just going to work out to be
some sort of in
some sort of an inner iterative scheme
for a number of steps this is going to
be hyperparameter
and this here this is something you can
technically do in parallel
you have to send a bit of information
around but you can technically do it in
parallel
this inner these inner loops
but you can you can just imagine it
always going from the back
and you distribute these errors you
refine your guesses a little bit and you
start from the back again you distribute
errors refine your guesses and so on and
you do that
you always start from the back um
in the actual code so you compute
these errors so this is your initial
guess and this is your refined guess
of the current layer and then you update
the vertex values you say
okay the
my guess for the next layer is going to
be
my guess for this layer plus some sort
of
a this gradient and this gradient we get
from equation number two
from this thing right here so my guess
is going to be updated such that i still
stay close
to my original guess but i
also update i also predict
better what the next layer is
and at the end when this is converged
you do the
update on the weights and the updates on
the weights
is simply again this what we saw it's
the error that you want to correct
so this e is the error you want to
correct
now you have a good approximation of the
error once this is converged
times the derivative of course
with respect to the weights so the error
is in terms of
how how much are your predictions off
from what they should be
and the derivative simply translates
that into the
how do you need to change the weights
such that in the future
that error is smaller okay
so then they show that this actually
approximates a back
prop and this it's a it's a fairly um
fairly simple proof it's an it's sort of
a proof by
induction uh by iteration that's showing
that
um one one such
one such thing like this this thing
right here at the equilibrium
at the last layer is equivalent to back
prop
because you can simply substitute this
and then by
sort of recursion um that
goes back the layers and this is all
dependent on you actually reaching that
equilibrium
which you do as we said by inner
iterations so they have a bit of a
they have a bit of an example right here
where they have this function
of um it's a pretty simple function this
function right here
uh the output is the tan of this square
root
and there's parameters in there right so
this is an arbitrary parameter that you
might want to
learn and then you give some data sets
so this is equal to two but i guess the
network doesn't
know that i don't know so you have to
learn it
and they they test that
and you can see this augmentation by
error graphs makes the computational
graph quite a bit
more um complex so you have all these
error graphs
right here but you know ultimately
er ultimately it's you can
you could automate this that that is not
a problem
okay so um they also do this for
as i said cnns rnns lstms
and the results are quite remarkable i
think
uh in that they they just follow
the same accuracy and and loss and
performance patterns
of these networks that's pretty cool the
downside of course is
that um they are way smaller
uh sorry they're way way slower and they
say this
sometimes due to the need to iterate the
v's until convergence the predictive
coding network
had roughly a 100 times greater
computational cost
than the backprop network though they
say this is
a bit misleading because you can
distribute
and parallelize that however
as we've seen it's not fully local like
you you need to send signal around every
node needs to send signal
to its parents or its children and um
that of course in in backprop you just
need to do that once
right so i'm not exactly buying this
argument of this is much more local and
so on
so the last thing that i want to point
out in the paper and then we
look briefly at the code is this thing
right here
there's a further simplification they
say importantly if the edge function
linearly combines the activities and the
parameters followed by an
element-wise non-linearity which is most
of
deep learning layers nowadays a
condition which we call parameter linear
then both the update rule for the
vertices and the parameters become
hebien
specifically the update rules for the
vertices and the weights become
so here is here is um
if you have a linear
operation followed by a non-linearity
which you know is the fact in rnns in
cnns
in fully connected layers then this here
are these update rules so the
local layer derivative
is simply going to be your forward
activations
passed through and this is a bit weird
um it's the forward activations
passed through the derivation of the
non-linearity
this is the non-linearity right here um
times again the weights of the forward
iteration
and the update rule with respect to the
parameters
are very very similar and the reason i
point this out because now we're going
to jump into the code
and i hope you can see this
you can recognize this again so first of
all
let's go into the um
into the cnn hello
all right so the code is quite ugly
honestly but um
you see that they have uh they've
backprop or
cnns but they have this thing right here
this um this model which
is the one they train and here is the
train function so in the train function
they go through the data set and you can
see for each
data point they simply call this infer
function right here
so this infer function is what
ultimately does
the training so in the infer function
they get an
input as you can see and a label and a
number of inference
steps so they start out
by and this this is
labeled a bit a bit different so they
have these
muse and the outs and these uh
prediction errors and the predictions
and
we're going to see how that works so
first of all they go through the layers
right here and i'm going to use my mouse
they go through the layers right here
and you can see they simply forward
propagate the signal so they always take
this mu of the last layer
they forward propagate it to get the mu
on the layer plus one and the outputs
are simply
cloned from the muse so these must be
our news before or our v's whatever you
want to call them
so one one is going to be the the
initial guess
and the other one is going to be the
guess that we iteratively
refine okay in fact the mu
here is going to be the guess that we
iteratively refine
at the beginning we simply set them to
be the same
okay and then the last layer here
we put at the label and then the
prediction errors
that's going to be yeah that's going to
be the the
error variables so the last prediction
error is going to be the derivative of
our loss function with respect to the
last layer and now
we start this iterative algorithm so
here you see we go through this number
of inference steps
train which is going to be like a
hundred or so so a hundred times
we're going to update each of our
guesses of the intermediate
layers then
here is what i said we're going through
the layers
in reverse order so 100 times we're
going from back to front back to front
back to front back to front and um
we do that so here you can see what the
first thing we do is we
come we compute the current error okay
which is the difference between the
guess
that we currently have and the initial
guess that we had during forward
propagation
this is going to be zero for most of the
layers at the beginning except
the last layer right in the last layer
we've actually
um put we've actually put the
the mu um to something else than the
output
and thus this error is going to
it's beginning at zero at each layer as
the guesses are the same but then we're
going to refine and refine and refine
and sort of this error of the last layer
is going to iteratively
propagate through the network to
the from the back to the front multiple
in an iterative fashion so multiple
times
so once we have the prediction error
we're going to
backward this through the layers and
this backward here that is
sort of that is this um
this backward edge we saw where did we
see this
so this backward is going to be the
this local derivative in this graph the
backward is going to be the the red
thing right here so we take
the error of the next layer and we're
going to
we're going to see how do we need to
change the current guess
in order to make the next layers error
be a little bit smaller so
that's the going to be the backward
function and we can actually look at the
backward function
of let's say
[Music]
yeah here so this
is the backward function of a fully
connected layer
this is the projection layer there is a
fully connect here as there's a fully
connected layer
and the f is going to be the
non-linearity and the df is going to be
the derivative of the non-linearity so
in the forward you can see
what we're doing is we're multiplying
the input by the weights
and then we're going to save the
activations
and simply propagate them through the
non-linearity
in the backwards we're going to take the
activations
this is the forward activation and we're
going to shove them through the
derivative
of the non-linearity and this is why i
pointed out this is this hebian
learning rule so first i was a bit
confused
why do we use the forward activations
and
shove them through the derivative of the
non-linearity
but this is exactly um this is simply
because they've derived that this is the
correct
local gradient okay and then
we have this right this is the local
gradient of the layer
and we're going to multiply that by the
weights so this
completes the formula that we had right
here for these hebbian
updates this thing
so these are the activations this is the
derivative of the forward layer
we're going to multiply that by the
weight again so this is now the complete
derivative
the complete local derivative
which is this thing i've already circled
50 billion times right here
and all we need to do now is we need to
multiply this
by the error in the prediction error in
that layer
and then we get an idea of how do we
need to change
this node such that in this one child
and there can be many children such that
in this one child
um we make a little bit less error
okay so
that's why we multiply this by e right
here so e
is the the error okay and
that would be the backwards thing so
backwards
simply tells the parent how it needs to
change
the child sorry how it needs to change
itself
such that the child is a little bit
happier and since this is a
forward you know a cnn we don't have
multiple children we simply have one
child per
parent so we have a list and
these predictions
as you can see we simply take the
prediction error of layer
j plus one we backward it so how do i
need to change this layer
in order to make it a little bit more
commensurate with the child
and then here is this trade-off
so the trade-off between the prediction
error
so how close am i to my original guess
i don't want to go too far away right
because i assume my original guess isn't
too bad
in fact there's a gaussian likelihood
model how i want to stay close to that
but also
i want to go into the direction such
that i make the next layer
happier okay this is this fundamental
tradeoff it's computed right here
and it's it's this minus sign
and then at the end this is the
inference learning rate
and um i simply go into
that direction of this trade-off okay
so i update the current the guess of the
current node like this
and as i said i go through the network
back to front back to front back to
front back to front
until i reach some sort of equilibrium
and only when i reach equilibrium or in
this case after this many steps
i then update the weights and the update
the weights function
that's very similar i think
here here is update weights
that is simply i each layer
i input the prediction error
of that layer and that layer
calculates this function right here in
much a
similar way than you just than you just
saw
maybe we can look at one of them
um let's go
this is layers let's go here
fully connected layer okay and you're
gonna see this habian
learning rule again so activations
through the derivative
um and so now
instead of so there's a little bit of a
difference to before right but the
difference isn't
isn't large right so activations
um multiplied by through this
and then multiplied by the inputs
instead of
the weights so that's that's that so um
this multiplied by the inputs instead of
the weights then multiplied
by e which is so
this here multiplied by the error term
right here and that's going to be our
local
update okay cool
um so that's the code that's predictive
coding and you know the challenge is
it's not that these people propose this
as
a true alternative to backprop but it is
a step in a direction of saying look the
brain
with its more heavy in nature and it's
more
local updates and so on it
could actually be doing something much
more close to backprop than we thought
because people thought well backdrop is
impossible in the brain
therefore the brain can't be doing back
prop
right and now we see that
actually the brain can do something
possibly it's not proven but it's
possible that the brain does something
that approximates the back prop gradient
um actually arbitrarily
if you know if all of these if these
some assumptions are given but
uh that's sort of the the results and
they also show it's quite robust too
learning rate changes and so on as we
said we can go pretty deep even though
this is this kind of
iterative guessing algorithm
under these gaussian assumptions and
there is variational approximation
it is fairly robust and all so
um this goes this sort of uh puts the
ball back into maybe the brain
is doing something very close
to backprop or at least uh getting the
same
results getting the same parameter
updates as backprop
so i hope that wasn't too confusing i've
tried to tackle it from many angles and
maybe after seeing the code you see it a
little bit more clearly
if not let me know open for questions as
always
and bye